I want to talk to you today about
Republican hypocrisy which has reached
heretofore unseen levels but this isn't
about one thing like okay you know we've
talked about vaccines and hypocrisy
before we had a decade where we talked
about gay marriage and hypocrisy from
the right this is a big picture issue
that if we can't Pierce in some way we
may never make progress on some really
important issues that affect the United
States and the world this story was
actually inspired by a subreddit user
who goes by the name department chair
who posted about this a few days ago on
the subreddit really good post and I
realize this is something we we should
be talking about right now and really
exposing the uh feckless nature of what
is supposedly the right wing philosophy
at this point in time because
Republicans claim to have at the center
of their political philosophy the
principles of non-intervention by
government into people's lives unless
completely necessary of not right
regulating business unless completely
necessary of a smaller government that
does fewer things being a better
government all else being equal this has
been floating around in Republican
circles
at least I mean but popularized during
the Reagan Era although you could
probably find examples of it before then
as well now you and I we've seen this be
utter garbage at the micro level they
say small government but they want the
government to ban gay marriage what hold
on what that doesn't make sense they say
small government
but they want the government policing
cannabis at the state and federal level
and that doesn't make sense but the
reality is that Republican policy on
endless issues is incredibly
interventionist
anti-libertarian
collectivist which they claim to be
against and in some cases it's even
oppressive to the degree that they want
to put policy in place and as our Reddit
user department chair points out often
this is the case with victimless crimes
flag burning as an example same-sex
marriage the Pledge of Allegiance in
school so just step back for a second
and think about all of the areas where
Republicans
self-professed so-called small
government conservatives have demanded
that government take action over the
last many decades I mean okay abortion
decisions that should be made between a
patient and a doctor for 50 years now
ban it federally they say ban it at the
state level they say regulate how many
what procedures do you have to have
before an abortion transvaginal
ultrasound and on and on and on regulate
Family Planning and they claim to be
small government conservatives that's
been going on for 50 years for more than
a decade it was the government should
ban same-sex marriage that was a huge
political issue for more than a decade
the the battle lines on gay rights have
shifted since the 2015 Supreme Court
decision but that was it for a decade
ban everything get the government
involved prevent teachers from deciding
what to teach ban the teaching of
critical race Theory control what
teachers teach as if you know more than
they know the War on Drugs I mean War on
Drugs policing of drugs prosecution
incarceration using it to justify
surveillance War on Drugs alone is like
10 items that that sort of follow from
that burning Flags something the Supreme
Court has decided is constitutionally
protected speech these Republicans they
want to ban it they want to punish
people a couple months ago we did a
segment where
I think it was at a trump rally an
interviewer was asking people what
should happen if somebody Burns a flag
some Republicans called for the death
penalty for burning a flag okay
surveillance an entire area in and of
itself now I will say there are some
Libertarians actual Libertarians not
just like reactionary right-wingers Who
hide under the name libertarian there
are some actual Libertarians who are
against uh much of the the surveillance
activity that has been put in place by
Patriot Act NSA Etc over the last decade
more but a lot of these right Wingers
say no no we need that we need that in
order to find antifa we need that in
order to monitor Muslims or whatever the
case may be okay
mandating the Pledge of Allegiance in
schools I mean you've got to be kidding
right no no many concert small
government government involved only when
absolutely necessary
requiring wanting to require the Pledge
of Allegiance be recited in school and
yet they have the audacity
to mention government intrusion and
small government and freedom and liberty
when they come out against vaccination
requirements even by private businesses
when they come out against Mass mandates
by municipalities or businesses and they
are even against private businesses
simply saying if you want to work here
you need a vaccine or if you want to
shop here you need a vaccine think of
that they claim to want businesses to do
to be able to do whatever the hell they
want they say don't regulate business
business will decide what's best and the
market will punish them if they do the
wrong thing but they say oh no make it
illegal for a businesses to require a
business to require an employee be
vaccinated make it illegal for a
business to require masks make it
illegal for a business to require
customers to show proof of vaccination
and why is it it's also simple guys it's
because their principles are BS they
don't really have principles at least
not anymore they are about whatever
talking Point sounds good right now
and it gets us what we want right now
that's what we believe in
that's what we stand for until it's no
longer convenient and then they're
against that very thing they're one
principle is somehow figure out a way to
own the libs it's truly one of the most
bad faith political movements I can
think of and you know you go back and
you look at the racist origins of the
War on Drugs in reaction to the civil
rights movement of the late 50s early
60s you look at the anti-welfare
movement of the Reagan Era and how
racially tinged that was and all all
these different there was a lot of bad
faith going on but at this point they're
barely even pretending to have
principles even their principles like
you hear them and it's like come on dude
that's BS you know you don't even
believe that because look at example one
two three four five six seven where you
abandon those principles because the
outcome of applying that principle would
no longer be the one you want so why do
we care about this we care about it
because since it has become the
Orthodoxy of the Republican party I mean
you want to see hypocrisy Mitch
McConnell on Supreme Court picks right
just just look it's the perfect example
of how this unbridled and unpunished
hypocrisy gets them political wins and
so if we don't find a way to pierce this
I worry seriously that the left will
struggle to really make progress on some
major important issues let me know what
you think okay you can find me and
follow me on Twitter at dpacman it's
great to be back we have a really big
show for you today I'll talk about my
vacation on the bonus show let me just
preview one aspect of the bonus show
today
positive
covid
test
that's all I'm going to say
on today's bonus show